あれーここ集合場所のようにおかしいなぁ
こんにちはエー
こんにちは駅的に取材を受け入れてくれた
花も実に偏見ある5層がよです
何年ぶりですか1年ぶですね今人間からですよ
ハロウィンでしょデパソル陰の季節に我々野菜は
まあ人間ぽい形になりここに帰ってくるといろいろ忍耐を教えてくれですよはい
任せてくださいいやー1年ぶりに行ったけど
名前変わらんだこの世界はん
ここはどこなんだここは海ですね
野菜初めてですか見るのはこんなにこっちの世界じゃないですか
いつも土ですよね色
これが人間の有様だ人間たちは相手の法律としているのか
いやそんなことはないよああ去年
緑色友だちーたじゃないですかー
プラダーなんだがあっこっこ図書いないんですかって言うよ
ほぼ者も連れてきてるを紹介してくださいよ
電車乗り遅れて
もうちょっとで届くからだッ
その他おねえさんに輸送すると今日の番組ではハロウィンの日にしか現れないかぼちゃ
人間の一日を密着取材してみようと思う
宮咲りあ
阪急開くにも負けず
しっかりと芽生えているだろうかこういう野菜達夫さんと平和に幸せにできる世界を
築きたいと思っている
すばらしいですねー
お友達はまだこのニャーイェイ前くらいからこのするキャンプですって
それからもう一つそれから来ドルが違います
だった
そろそろとばらつきますかねえ
もうすぐ来ると思っているはずん
これじゃあこの世界の水かー
そこら辺にいるって増法ちゃったてーってに出たから多分設ける
b 2分
だぞ8
ああああああ
去年の友達スイカ組んだ
二人は出会うと同時に
寂しい12
人間がいの海を眺めていた
誰も去年こっちの世界できたがまだ言葉が喋れな
今回新しく
仲良し
そうしていっ
パーティ
子供達はもうつくったパリ p
それを覚えた
誰かいます
キャップって
うーん大正製薬ハッシュは人間用品除
実際人間どもが冷たいわけで個ついてくる
やめだ
tan tan
ちゃうよ
tee
ラメてよああ
今日は確かもう一人ぐらいクリオてだったんだけど
隋書ですかねぇああ
そこには
4歳人間に対する人間たちの凶悪な現実が待つ構えていた上に行くねー
どうぞあああああああ
大丈夫か
こいつぁー
今日初めて人間界にスターブドウだ
不同意はそいじゃねーじゃんかよええっ
えっ彼ら野菜人間はいつになったら人間たちに馴染めるのだろうか
そんな未来を描き
彼らはん
人間界を満喫していた
いやー
なんか前と変わらず
思ったり平和だったんだよ
いや良かったと思います
さあちょっとちょっと何やってるんですかやめてくださいよやめてくださいってまぁ
あ